it's not about being submissive you just
have to be kind and you have to be
loving and you have to respect your man
a lot of women don't actually respect
their men yes they like them they're
attracted to them they love them but
they don't actually respect them and I
feel like men want respect from women
and they don't get that enough well I
agree with you but why is that not
submission isn't that part of submission
no because I still have a voice you
don't think submissive women have voices
I don't know I feel like if I'm just
going to be saying yes to everything and
doing everything that my man wants then
I've kind of lost sense of who I am